les clark se sont installés dans l'indre
il ya 16 ans retraité de l'armée richard
et son épouse christine coulé depuis des
jours heureux dans un village où huit
familles anglaises vives où réside
depuis le vote entérinant le bric sic
les questions sur leur avenir restent
sans réponse en premier la
revalorisation de leurs pensions et le
remboursement des soins médicaux comme
les gens qui habitent australie les
avaient gagné leurs retraites le
gouvernement
mais après ça chaque année les na'vi par
les augmentations et peut-être si ne
n'est pas dangereux
peut-être c'est le même pour nous je ne
sais pas si c'est difficile pour les
effets médical sur l'écran de télé du
couple la retransmission du débat en
direct autour des propositions de
theresa may le premier ministre jugé
trop laxiste laisse craindre le pire
mais manqua plutôt improbable de nouveau
référendum
le couple ne pourrait participer comme
tous ceux qui vivent depuis plus de 15
ans hors de leur pays
ils ont le sentiment que leur avis ne
compte pas même s'ils ont doublé une
grande partie de leur vie au pays
accepte mais ils sont nés comme prince
pour pouvoir rester en france ils ont dû
constituer tout un énorme dossier afin
de faire en temps une demande de carte
de séjour avant que les services
français ne croulent sous les demandes
un sacré retour en arrière pour ce
couple demander la nationalité française
trop prématuré richard pense qu'il y ait
un risque pour sa pension
deux militaires